Hi zusammen! Wir machen heute ein weiteres Apfelkuchen Rezept.
Ich finde Apfelkuchen - da kann man nie genug von haben!
Und ich hab das letztens ausprobiert das Rezept, dann nochmal richtig schön verfeinert
und entstanden ist ein super fluffiger, leckerer Apfelkuchen, der sehr intensiv schmeckt.
Und ich starte jetzt auch direkt mit der Küchenmaschine und gebe da zuallererst Butter rein.
Die ganz genauen Mengenangaben findet ihr wie immer...
*Grillenzirpen*
[Kiki] Das sagst du doch immer!
[Hamza] Achso, ich dachte - *lacht* In der Infobox!
In der Infobox, genau!
So, jetzt gebe ich erstmal die weiche Butter (die sollte auch schön Zimmertemperatur haben) - Moment! - in die Küchenmaschine.
Ich gebe da Zucker mit dazu, außerdem noch Vanilleextrakt und eine gute Prise Salz.
Salz hebt einfach nochmal den süßen Geschmack.
Und dann rühren wir das auf mittlerer bis hoher Geschwindigkeit ca. 3min lang.
So, und danach die Eier nur ganz kurz unterrühren.
Und jetzt nehme ich mir eine Bio Zitrone - Bio deshalb damit ihr auch die Schale verwenden könnt -
und reibe das einmal in die Masse.
Wichtig ist Leute, super super wichtig: dass ihr nur die gelbe Schale abreibt, nicht das Weiße.
Das Weiße schmeckt bitter und dann würdet ihr euch den ganzen Teig versauen,
daher nochmal der Hinweis.
Und nachdem ich das dazugegeben habe, gebe ich auch direkt Mehl und Backpulver noch dazu,
siebe das aber damit's auch 100%-ig klümpchenfrei ist
und dann verrühre ich das nur noch ganz kurz.
[Hamza] Was passiert denn wenn man's nicht siebt?
Also eigentlich bei so 'nem Rührteig wenn man nicht gerade die Eier trennt,
muss man's sogar gar nicht sieben aber je nach Lagerung, je nachdem, wie's dann im Schrank gelagert ist,
können echt hartnäckige Klümpchen entstehen und Backpulver-Stückchen auch
und so vermeidet man das einfach.
[Kiki] Hamza, sehr gute Frage!
[Hamza] Ja!
[Hamza] Wollte ich schon immer wissen, jetzt ehrlich!
So, und jetzt benötigen wir noch Äpfel natürlich.
Da habe ich die Schale entfernt und die Äpfel einfach in kleine Stückchen geschnitten.
Und außerdem benötigen wir Apfelmus. Entweder den fertig gekauften -
Ich hatte jetzt keinen da und hab's ganz schnell selbst gemacht.
Super easy: Einfach Äpfel mit Wasser 5min lang köcheln lassen und dann pürieren.
Es darf auch ruhig noch lauwarm sein, nur nicht mehr ganz so heiß.
So und jetzt geht's schon mal an unsere Springform.
Ich habe hier die Größe von 26cm, gebe da auf den Boden Backpapier
und dann verteile ich erstmal den Teig da drauf.
Leute, das isses!
Das macht den Kuchen nochmal richtig saftig!
So, die Apfelstücke habe ich drauf verteilt, soweit, so gut!
Jetzt kommen aber noch Streusel. So ein richtig leckerer Apfelkuchen braucht richtig geile Streusel!
Und da habe ich jetzt auch wieder zimmerwarme Butter.
Da gebe ich Mehl dazu - Ärmel hochkrempeln, meine Hände sind natürlich sauber!
Mehl dazu, Zucker dazu, Vanilleextrakt..
Und zum Schluss gebe ich noch gehobelte Mandeln da drauf.
So, die Streusel sind fertig. Jetzt kommen eigentlich die Mandeln dazu
aber da müsst ihr ganz vorsichtig sein damit ihr die nicht kaputt brecht.
Also ganz vorsichtig nur einrühren.
[Hamza] Kiki du hast so zarte Hände, da passiert schon nichts!
[Kiki] Jaja!
[Hamza] Du hast so zarte Händchen, du!
Boah das riecht - das riecht soo lecker! Das riecht richtig gut!
So, das war's schon!
Den Ofen habe ich vorgeheizt auf 180° C,
da braucht er so ca. 30-35min, sollte natürlich nicht zu dunkel werden.
Und ihr könnt natürlich auch hier die Stäbchenprobe machen.
Und es riecht so gut!
Meine Nase denkt sich grad so: "Hä, was geht da ab in Kikis Kitchen?!"
Apfelmus riecht man gerade voll aus, die Zitrone - also diesen Abrieb
und das Vanilleextrakt, richtig geil! Und die Butter natürlich.
Riecht auf jeden Fall sehr angenehm und wir sehen uns nach dem Backen wieder.
Ich lass es aber komplett auskühlen und dann gebe ich später noch Puderzucker da drüber.
Also bis gleich!
[Hamza] Hey, was riecht hier so lecker bei Kikis Kitchen?! *lacht*
So, jetzt hole ich meinen Apfelkuchen nur noch aus der Form und gebe ihn auf 'ne hübsche Platte,
ich nehme hier meine Schieferplatte.
Und dann Leute, würde ich mal sagen: Gönnt euch diesen Kuchen, der ist super saftig und super lecker!
Das mit dem Apfelmus habe ich ganz spontan ausprobiert und das gefällt mir richtig gut!
Also den dürft ihr auf keinen Fall weglassen.
So, perfekt! Ein bisschen Puderzucker noch dazu und fertig.
Leute, den liebt einfach jeder!
Also der gehört zu meinen Top 3 Apfelkuchen Rezepten!
Ich werde euch übrigens eine Playlist mit all meinen Apfel Rezepten hier unten in die Videobeschreibung verlinken
und dann könnt ihr euch mal durchklicken.
Macht erst den nach und dann macht ihr alle anderen nach. Gut? Einverstanden?
Weil der ist wirklich sehr, sehr lecker und wenn ihr ihn dann nachmacht,
freue ich mich wenn ihr zurückkommt zu meinem Video und mir Feedback da lasst
und generell auch meinem Kanal ein kostenloses Abo hinterlasst, dann verpasst ihr nämlich solche Rezepte auch nicht mehr.
Falls ihr mehr Apfel Rezepte sehen möchtet oder auch mit anderem
- fast hätte ich Gemüse gesagt! - mit anderem Obst, dann einfach in die Kommentare reinschreiben.
Und ansonsten habt noch einen wunderwunderschönen Tag und bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen, Tschüss!
[Hamza] Eure Kiki!
[Kiki] Eure Kiki und der Hamza hinter der Kamera!
[Kiki] Tschüss!
[Hamza] Gönn dir!